if you ever make a big time make sure
you help those in need
when i do business it's never about the
monetary aspect it's about changing
people's lives
uh letting people you know understand
that you know you can still have fun
so that's what i wanted to do i wanted
to be like hey whenever i do business
it's not about the money you know
muhammad ali said you could tell a lot
about a man how he treats the janitor
if a man treats a janitor like he gonna
treat everybody like
so after that i was like you know what i
need to
i need to just just stay cool because
all this could be taken away especially
if you make crazy decisions so
you know my thing is
take care of my family
lead by example for people
like us you know people want to follow
in our footsteps
criticism to me is a double-edged ward
you can take it and listen to it and
fade away
or you can listen to it find some truth
in it
and better yourself
i don't let people tell me what i can
and can't do
it won't happen it don't matter what
they say you gotta whatever you believe
you go for it and you gotta understand
before you succeed you must first learn
to fail
like if you fail one or two times and
you and you stop pursuing your dream you
ain't ready anyway
he told me he said
you're rich
but i'm wealthy
because i didn't know the difference
i said what's what's the difference he
said well wealthy is when i die
my kids die when they kids die when they
kids die we still have the same amount
and i thought about that then i said
okay how you doing and he pulled out a
piece of paper
after he said it ain't about how much
you make it's about how much you keep
how many times we've seen cats we get
the bag with a hundred and then then
they go blow it the same way now they
got to get another hundred so he said if
you got a hundred dollars
you save that that's 50.
that he said rich people say okay i'm
saving 50 and i'm doing that but he said
the wealthy does this
[Music]
you save that this ball out
house chain car whatever you want but
75
save it yeah that's what he said
it took a lot of
strong discipline and i i got touched up
a few times but only thing i could do is
thank you like
i've been able to just to to live how i
want to live and do what i want to do
because i listen like you know his main
thing listen listen listen once i
started listening
doors started opening up my dream in
high school was to make 8 million for 10
years i was able to get 40 million my
first contract but because i listened
and because i had that discipline i'm i
didn't play basketball in 15 years but i
live a really really good life
it's a shame that you know 60 of
uh professional athletes after they're
done they have nothing
so then i said okay
i don't want to be like the rest of
these nba players i got to teach myself
because this is something that we don't
know like you know my family work work
uh paycheck to paycheck we never had no
money but i had to get that bins i had
to get my mom a bit like i just had to
get that first so after i spent that
million dollars in the day
i sort of you know educated myself and
it's okay not to know nothing so if you
don't know nothing just ask questions
so everybody i saw that was successful
how you do that
how you do that how you do that and the
first book i bought was the dummy's
guide to starting your own business
everybody everybody should get that book
because they give you all the answers on
how to start a business how to be
successful what to look for so after
that
i became a little more literate but i
still didn't
didn't know a lot all the stuff i'm
doing now that's the stuff that i wanted
to do i want to invest
i want to buy companies i want to be on
boards i want to do certain things
because
you know may not be a husband but i'm
always be a father and the father job
was to protect provide and love
two wonderful women
that have given me beautiful gorgeous
children i have to protect and i have to
provide and i have to love for them
forever that's why i work so hard i
don't work for me i got it all i got to
work for them i got to work for my six
babies being a ceo starts up here
everybody in this room is already a ceo
[Music]
you know you don't have to be a you
don't have to own a business to be a ceo
being a ceo is a mentality
if you have that mentality if you have
that belief
it will work of course there's gonna be
some ups and downs when i first
started
sell ten thousand pair twenty thousand
pair fifty thousand pair and then it
just kept going so you know i've been
doing it since since 95 so 95 to now
that's what 30 something years
400 million pair and then i went to
china and did the same thing
and jerry what said look i know you like
to rap and do movies and all that but
when it's all said and done
if it's done the right way your name
could be up there so while some people
look at it as pressure i look at it as a
challenge not only do i look at the
challenge from where i come from i got
to get it done and now i got kids and
boys too and for bragging rights i gotta
get it done
listen to your mother and father
i wasn't the smartest guy in the world
was the brightest guy in a room but i
listened to my mother and father
they believed in my dream they made me
believe in my dream
and i just i just wanted to fight i'm a
fighter like when you tell me i can't do
nothing i'ma just go and do it nobody
could be as famous as magic and kareem
you'll never win and all that i'm saying
okay you're a nobody i'm a somebody i
ain't trying to hear all that and you
know you just keep fighting so the first
four years me and kobe we got swept we
didn't give up we just kept going and
then we won three in a row i got traded
you all know the story but again
it doesn't matter what anybody tell you
it's what you believe
the ceo is mental
[Music]
and when you love something and you
respect it you can always do well at it
so doing well for me is not the same
definition as a rapper even if i go 10
times platinum that money ain't doing
nothing for me
and then you say you should develop
something called one hand stress
i only care about what my mama say
what my kids think
if it's gonna mess up the money in the
business
what my boys think that's it it don't
even get to five then i made up a quote
for myself if a nobody can influence
somebody then the nobody wins but the
question of the day is who are you
nobody
so all these people with their opinions
if we talking pecking order status i
don't mean be disrespectful but you're
under me so i used to see this guy a man
of god and i said how do you stay rich
and he pulled out a hundred dollar bill
and he ripped it in half
and he said what's this i said 50 50.
said
you save 50. that's cool and spin this
but he said the wealthy people do this
you say this
ball out with that
whatever you want to do so i didn't
really spend none of my checks until i
got married
when it comes to position like that i've
seen greatness i've i've helped bring
greatness up
i played with penny i played with kobe i
played with d-wade i played with brian i
play with nash
so i know what greatness is so when i
see somebody that has that it's my job
to push him but again when i when i say
oh he's hating no i don't
i don't have to hate brother uh you know
education is something that can never be
taken away from me have to retire from
basketball you have to retire from nfl
you have to retire from being a rapper
you have to retire from being an actor
but if you don't have education
while you're doing all that you'll be
one of those stories that we all know
about
[Music]